brothers and sisters he's telling me i
used to struggle reading the quran daily
before you instructed instructed me to
download this app brothers and sisters
can you imagine someone struggling and
he has downloaded the quran app and
built a habit and now he's regularly
reading you can go into the description
box click the link for ios and android
and build your habit with the quran
right now
[Music]
brothers and sisters in dear friends i
don't know about you guys but i've been
getting a lot of recommendations on my
youtube channel for some reason about
johnny depp and his wife amber
i tried ignoring this i spoke to some
some brothers etc and i said you know
let me look into this i can't i find it
fascinating i was like what enough is
going on i have no idea i'll be honest
with you and it's basically about two
people who are married a domestic
violence case which is one is amber is
suing johnny depp johnny depp's been
quite valid now he's coming out people
say things have been shifted etc to his
favor whatever first thing first i want
to make a disclaimer i'm not here to
take anybody's side um domestic abuse
physical abuse is something very very
seriously and i'm not here to take sides
because i don't know the full story and
we are told that this is
along the lines of basically don't hear
one side and make a judgment and we all
do that we hear somebody you know come
in and say that another about my wife
and this anything one evil wife or some
sister comes and starts crying my
husband listen you're thinking one evil
guy et cetera and then you look into the
mat and you're like you didn't tell me
the full story here so i'm just giving a
disclaimer that it's an ongoing case
mine is just something that i want to
bring to you guys pertaining to quran i
don't think these videos just for the
sake of because it's a hot topic but
because how we can relate quran sunnah
into this matter and how islam tells us
to deal with the situation which i
believe is
some sort of i think is the absolute
solution to actually so obviously guys
one first of all since that screams out
of the way now first reactions what is
the first reaction well sadly this first
reactions that we have the media have
and the industry has well the industry's
first reaction to this was that they
fired johnny depp from the pirates of
the caribbean
now the question is that okay they've
heard these claims etc which amber made
his her his wife but the funny thing is
from what we know she hasn't been fired
now the question is why not
because it goes back to the case of
hearing one side of the story and now
we're finding out which she herself has
admitted the following
i'm sorry that i didn't uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched
which you guys heard for yourself yeah
so that she admits that she didn't punch
him but hit him okay so why is it that
she didn't get fired why is it that she
didn't lose her job why is it that
automatically the first reaction to this
is the industry fires the man let's be
fair in justia why is it seen as that
the men are the only only violent ones
yes statistics kind of show you know
that men are more violent than women but
this doesn't mean that in every single
case you can generalize and make it seem
as if he is the aggressor yeah that's
that's the point i'm trying to make when
it comes to the industry level
media has kind of jumped on the
bandwagon as well again you know and
these industries and these media they do
this not because they favor one or the
other it's because they know if they
take you know because because women are
seen as vulnerable you know you have to
take
her aside that's the get go and we also
do that ourselves so the industry does
it the media does it we also do it when
it comes to these matters like our first
impressions is what
bad husband etc and we start you know
projecting the things that we live
through to an individual if you was in a
household where your
father was violent to your mom and then
we think yeah he's the same no maybe
he's not the same maybe he's the victim
maybe i'm saying can it be yes so our
first reactions should be that it
shouldn't be no he's a van why is it
that he's guilty until proven innocent
and she's innocent until proven guilty
why is that the case
that is not right i know of many cases
where brothers are you know wallahi were
like cases where the woman's got a knife
in her hand throwing bottles
throwing bottles coming physically you
know again i'm not taking anybody's side
journey depths or embers here okay what
i'm trying to say is we cannot have
double standards now secondly
where does where is this all stemming
from now feminism is the wrong answer to
the right questions okay a lot of cases
men being violent you know men
mistreating men being abusive etc this
happens vice versa but these are
questions valid questions that
muslim women and non-muslim women are
asking but you're asking the right
questions but you're getting the wrong
answers from feminism feminism is there
to basically destroy you gradually and
slowly and systematically that's exactly
what its objective and its aim is
because what it does to you as a woman
is that it makes you that for example
which is very
strange that
why are men the bar that you need to be
why is it that you have to be like us
i mean isn't it self-defeating that we
are your success measurements like oh i
have to be like you whatever you do i
need to do the same
why do you have to be like me you are
unique in your own way why do you have
to be like me why is the bar there like
i mean isn't it self-defeating like we
have to be like men if men do this we're
going to do that if men that we're going
to do that i think this is maybe the
reason why we are now seeing a spike in
females and women becoming violent
what is it is this what feminism toxic
femininity has taught you that now you
have to become like a man and like you
know i'm going to take the matters
physically you know maybe he will
understand in the physical no
no that is not correct and that is what
exactly feminism is doing is is trying
to destroy the nuclear family it's as
simple as that that's what it's doing
systematically and we can see that and
they say chivalry is dead yeah it's dead
and women killed it
women killed it you know they want to
have their cake and eat it you know
chivalry is dead and i'm so sorry you
guys are the murderers you guys are i'm
so sorry females not all but what i'm
trying to say is the cause of that we
have swapped our roles yes with some of
those men have become like women women
have become like men and very
interestingly allah in the quran says
something very profound because when it
comes to this issue the quran speaks
very very you know vividly about this
subhanallah in the quran
says that allah acknowledges the men's
responsibility and acknowledges the
woman's responsibility and gives you
guidance according to who how you're
created near not what you think you are
or but realistically what what you are
not who you think you are but what you
are and allah says in the quran and in
surah 4 34 men are the caretakers of
women and maintainers and protections of
women as men have been provisioned
by allah over women and tasked with
supporting them financially and
righteous women are devoutly obedient
and when alone protect of what allah has
entrusted with them yeah so allah
subhanahu wa tala very very
gives the role of a man is the
maintainer and the protector he's the
one that should provide should provide
for you he should be taking care of you
he should protect you because you are
phys biologically you are physically
weak if a person with a knife comes i'm
not going to send my wife it's my duty i
acknowledge i don't say no you know why
do i have to go why don't you go and
i'll just be here you know backing you
up cheering you yeah you go go you punch
him in the face yeah no islam
acknowledges that and that is a big risk
that means i'm putting my life i'm like
a full-time bodyguard i put my life on
the line for my wife my sister my mother
my daughter and rightly so and i'm proud
i don't have a problem with that can you
imagine if i had the problem with this
and said no i want to be like a woman
yeah and i want that no you go fight
would with feminism were feminists like
that they wouldn't they wouldn't they
they tried their best to like oh no no
no sorry nature reality shows you that
no and then also men are weak in certain
areas where they require a woman to step
up that is our reality and also when it
comes to this of marriage conflict the
quran on this one is very very
clear about this now
are we saying that for example the
videos that we've watched that
that men are in no way shape or form in
any instance in any situation not to put
their hands on a woman
any one of you guys would agree with me
that no that's not correct because if a
woman has been aggressive
yeah and i'm not saying but i'm talking
about amber these are accusation
speculation um these are things that um
johnny depp is claiming yeah just like
amber's claiming so i'm not taking
anybody's side the thing is this though
to those accusation claims yeah if it is
real that bottles have been thrown your
fingers nearly cut you've been punched
in the face two times yeah and etc etc
etc whatever are you telling me that i
am going to just stand there and get
punches like that i'm sorry i'm not
going to let anyone come and punch me
two times in the face yeah i would
restrain her i would restrain her like
anybody does so in the quran allah says
if you sense ill conduct from your wives
advise them so the first step is what
allah the legislative system gives us a
protocol yeah because many men or many
individuals don't have a protocol so
what they do is they go straight
physically and being their wife's up you
know because their best for their team
their favorite team lost they come home
and take out on their wives which is
absolutely haram so the point is this
number one is what you advise look
you've been behaving like this etc in a
threatening manner or whatever it may be
i don't like that yeah please stop here
allah tells us the advice if this
carries on allah tells us the second
thing which is what that you move away
from the bed
sexually obviously emotionally you are
depriving her so she can understand that
she's hurting you and that she should
stop doing what she's doing that's what
allah's parents are saying and thirdly
if you see her transgressing where she's
getting physical picking up bottles
knife trying to come and punch you allah
says then you can use a force to
restrain them you can use a force okay
now in this case where johnny just been
punched in the face yeah we know very
clearly it's haram to hit yeah it's
haram to hit the face okay it's haram to
hit the face a man doing it to a woman
wife to a husband or husband to a wife
it is not permissible for anyone to get
physically violent to cause harm injury
pain yeah to the opposite gender et
cetera it is not permissible yeah
restraining et cetera it's a different
story okay trying to restrain someone
trying to attack you so allah subhanahu
wa is given a protocol what to do not
only that in different verses allah says
get your family members together and try
to reconcile now the thing is here which
is very interesting is in the same
chapter a bit further down allah
subhanahu wa tala also talks about when
a man is transgressing but look at what
allah subhanahu tala says and addresses
it in such a way which puts us back to
where allah is telling us that a woman's
role biologically physically in
different ways
because what allah advises is not the
same thing check this out
allah says in the quran
and if a woman fear
from a husband yeah contempt or a vision
evasion there is no sin upon them if
they make terms of settlement between
them and their settlement is best and
present in human souls
but if you do good fear allah so in a
nutshell if you see it allah didn't give
the same protocol to the woman
allah didn't say that you do these steps
and then after that you take you try to
restrain him because allah wa
acknowledges that the woman doesn't have
the physical power to
take restraint or whatever it may be so
allah doesn't advise her to do that
because that could cause for example if
she tries to become physical with him he
can overpower her so allah is protecting
the rights of a woman in this very
instance by not advising the same thing
when he told a woman for a man that
restrain him because he has the power to
stop her from attacking him but the
woman doesn't have the power to do vice
versa so he allah subhanahu was
acknowledged a woman's role and a man's
role biologically and how they are
created but feminism is doing the
opposite by saying no you be like kim
you're you know what go from stop punch
him in the face
and this is the problem here
we need to acknowledge that how we are
created biologically and our pros and
cons that what we can do and we can't do
it's as simple as that that's what we
need to acknowledge and that's exactly
what allah is going back to the nuclear
family supply of men are the maintainers
and the protectors and of course women
have a major major role that play in
that as well you know
into that for the household and allah
says when you divorce women and they
have fulfilled their turn either retain
them retain them according to accept to
return or release them according to
acceptable terms and do not keep them
intending harm to transgress against
them and whoever does that has certainly
wronged themselves and do and
and do not take the verse of allah in
just and remember the favor of allah
upon you so allah saying look you've
gone down the divorce route
go about it amicably bye-bye bye-bye
it's simple as that and the prophet
peace be upon him was also like that
when once he had a dish that he brought
from one of his other other wives and
aisha and his other wife cooked she got
generous and she smashed the whole plate
in front of the whole companions i mean
guys what would we do if that was us and
the prophet peace be upon him laughed
and he said look your mother's got upset
subhanallah and it teaches you and the
prophet peace be upon him was never
amongst those who hit his wives yeah but
in this very situation we look at johnny
depp from what we can see we have an
amber story as well but from what we've
heard is that he is being physically he
has is alleging that he was physically
attacked bottles being thrown punched in
the face etc we need to address this
issue this issue is not just pertaining
to
men hit their wives i'm so sorry there
are women that are physically abusing
their husbands and i have heard and
witnessed it myself
and that's what allah and his messenger
has legislated for us as muslim men to
deal with and muslim women as well that
you have protocols in place family
members in place to amicably
resolve the issue
alhamdulillah for islam and to be honest
like i said before that's all i wanted
to say we should never ever
judge and jump to assumptions and
accusations because what happens is we
end up emulating ourselves just because
we heard one story yeah okay it can be
the case we don't know when it's
finalized that amber was the
transgressor and he's she's been taking
everyone for a ride from the get-go just
because she's a woman doesn't mean she's
innocent if he's guilty until proven
innocent she should also be guilty until
proven sin that's all i have to say on
the matter may allah bless every single
one of you guys for watching until next
time assalamualaikum